Justice Department internal watchdog
will investigate at the FBI probe of the
Trump campaigns ties to Russia was
politically motivated in a tweet
president Trump demanded an answer about
whether the FBI had an informant
infiltrate his presidential campaign at
the request of the Obama administration
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
good morning good morning Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosen Stein didn't
wait for a direct order from President
Trump before handing this issue off to
the Office of Inspector General so he
has given the president something
without fully caving to his
unprecedented demand this move is seen
as a way to de-escalate the situation as
the president and his lawyers ramped up
their attacks on the Russia
investigation yet bothers me that they
may be an informant in one of the
campaign's unless there's a damn good
reason Senator Lindsey Graham backed up
the president's outrage on Sunday in the
middle of a tweet storm mr. Trump wrote
I hereby demand and will do so
officially tomorrow that the Department
of Justice look into whether or not the
FBI
DOJ infiltrated or surveil the Trump
campaign for political purposes career
justice officials view the president's
tweet as highly inappropriate as
traditionally the Justice Department has
operated independently from the White
House California Democrat Adam Schiff
this claim by the president's suggestion
by Giuliani that there is a political
spy embedded in the Trump campaign is
nonsense the president was seizing on
media reports about an FBI informant who
made contact with at least three Trump
campaign advisers Carter page George
papadopolis and Sam Clovis after the FBI
learned that at least two of them had
suspicious contacts with Russian
officials Papadopoulos has pled guilty
in the Russia probe and is cooperating
with special counsel Muller a few hours
after the president's tweet the Justice
Department asked its internal watchdog
to investigate whether there was any
impropriety Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein said if anyone did infiltrate
or surveil participants we need to know
about it last week House Intelligence
Committee Chairman Devin Nunez
subpoenaed the Justice Department for
all documents related to the informant
but officials rejected the request
warning that exposing him could put the
informant in danger
it's not clear whether this decision to
hand this issue off to the internal
watchdog will satisfy the president in
the past he has criticized the Inspector
General for being too slow in his
investigations and also the fact that
the Inspector General doesn't actually
have prosecutorial power but if the
Inspector General finds any evidence of
criminal wrongdoing he can pass that off
to the Justice Department for possible
prosecution Nora alright Paula thank you